mobbing ist schlimmer als misshandlungen
raumschiff stürzt ab und sport hilft gar
nicht beim abnehmen das sind drei der
fünf themen jetzt in den kriegs und
taschen hey entdeckt im golf von mexiko
gelang forschern ein außergewöhnlicher
fund erst zwei mal konnte ein taschen
hai gefangen werden
der letzte fund nahe chile ist schon
über 30 jahre lang her den namen bekam
der hai damals aufgrund von zwei taschen
die sich etwas oberhalb seiner
seitlichen flossen befinden
der hai hat eine äußerst seltsame
farbgebung much farben und einen
gewaltigen kopf ähnlich dem kopf des
weißen hais gefangen wurde der neue
taschen bereits 2010 jetzt erst wurden
studien zu derart verfasst mehrere jahre
lang das männliche tier in einem
gefrierfach und wartete auf die forscher
der gefundene taschen hat eine länge von
40 14 cm es richtig war 2010 ein wenige
wochen altes tier und bereitet den
forschern viel arbeit
bisher kann sich niemand wirklich
erklären warum diese art taschen an den
seiten hat erste vermutungen gehen davon
aus dass der hai so sekrete ausscheidet
sicher ist das jedoch noch lange nicht
die bisher nahezu einzige erkenntnis zu
der art das letzte exemplar war in etwa
40 zentimeter groß und ein weibchen
dieser gewaltige größenunterschied zudem
2010 gefundenen männlichen taschen hey
lässt die wissenschaftler darauf
schließen dass die weiblichen tiere
größer werden als die männlichen die
menschen das gefühl geben er sei
unsichtbar in stockholm tricksten
forscher ihre probanden so stark aus
dass sie das gefühl hatten unsichtbar zu
sein gelungen ist den wissenschaftlern
das durch sinnestäuschung unser gehirn
lässt sich relativ leicht täuschen
sobald es keine offensichtlichen gegen
sprüche erkennt nimmt es einfach an was
es beispielsweise zu sehen und
gleichzeitig zu spüren bekommt und wenn
das eigentlich überhaupt keinen sinn
macht trotzdem denkt sich das hören dass
das gehirn akzeptiert keine konflikte
und versucht deshalb einfach noch so
sinnlose wahrnehmen zu verknüpfen
das nutzen die wissenschaftler jetzt aus
den teilnehmern wurde einer virtual
reality brille aufgesetzt und sie wurden
dann in einen leerstehenden raum
begleitet zunächst wurde ihnen über den
körper gestrichen
parallel dazu spielte sich auf den
bildschirm der brille eine gleiche
handbewegung des forschers jedoch in der
luft ab nach einer weile bekamen die
probanden das gefühl nicht existent zu
sein und verknüpften die berührung an
ihrem körper mit dem bild in der brille
sie spürten eine berührung sahen aber
nur die handbewegung des forschers im
leeren raum den ganzen versuch über
sollten die probanden den kopf gesenkt
lassen
das wirkliche gefühl von unsichtbarkeit
verspürten sie erst als sie den kopf
heben sollten in den bildschirm spielte
sich dann eine menschenmenge ab die bei
dem versuch zuschaute der puls der
teilnehmer blieb nahezu unverändert
warum sie hatten das gefühl
niemand könne sie wahrnehmen eine
heftige stressreaktion des körpers die
konnte gemessen werden als die forscher
mit einem messer in der luft stocherten
die probanden vermuteten schließlich
dort ihren körper unfassbar wie man
unser gehirn täuschen und damit solche
reaktionen auslösen kann
sport hilft nicht beim abnehmen den
kampf gegen das übergewicht muss man
nicht mit der waffe sport angehen wenn
man abnehmen will sollte man sich nicht
auf training verlassen sondern vielmehr
auf seine ernährung achten
das berichten britische forscher im
british journal of sports medicine
besonders stark nahmen die experten die
lebensmittelindustrie in die pflicht sie
dürfe den konsumenten nicht mehr den
irrglauben vermitteln dass man nahezu
alles essen kann solange man sich
sportlich betätigt ein übergewichtiger
braucht kein bisschen sport um
abzunehmen
man muss einfach weniger essen mein
größtes problem ist die botschaft dass
man essen kann
was man will so lange man trainiert das
ist unwissenschaftlich und falsch eine
schlechte ernährung kann man nicht weg
trainieren so aus ihm mal hott gegen
sport an sich haben die forscher nicht
sportliche aktivitäten sehen sie als
gutes werkzeug gegen diabetes zum
beispiel herzerkrankungen und demenz den
wissenschaftlern zufolge sei eine
falsche ernährung dennoch an mehr
erkrankungen schuld als alkohol rauchen
und fehlende bewegung mobbing schlimmer
als misshandlungen
wir alle wissen wie böse kinder
zueinander sein können auch jugendliche
forderten auch andere leute eine neue
studie befasst sich jetzt mit der
thematik ob sich mobbing zwischen
kindern und jugendlichen gleichen alters
stärker auf die psyche auswirken kann
als misshandlung etwa 5500 probanden
nahmen an der studie teil ergebnis im
alter von 18 jahren sei es
wahrscheinlicher dass man aufgrund von
mobbing eine depression oder andere
derartige erkrankungen entwickelt als
aufgrund von misshandlungen die kinder
beziehungsweise jugendliche wurden zum
einen mündlich befragt mussten
fragebögen ausfüllen und zum anderen
wurden auch ihre eltern befragt thema
der befragung und fragebögen mögliche
erfahrungen mit mobbing und
misshandlungen ausgewertet wurden die
fragebögen und die gespräche dann im
zusammenhang mit sämtlichen ärztlichen
unterlagen die zu den probanden
existierten also jede menge arbeit wurde
betrieben ein richtig breite studie um
auf das ergebnis zu kommen das mobbing
ein immer größer werdendes problem ist
zeigen etliche studien studien zufolge
hat nahezu jedes dritte kind auf der
welt mit mobbing zu kämpfen
die jetzt veröffentlichte studie soll
nicht zum ausdruck bringen dass
misshandlungen weniger schlimm sein als
mobbing sowohl mobbing als auch
misshandlungen sind riesige gefahren die
viel zu oft verschwiegen werden
raumschiff stürzt ab der
weltraumfrachter progress m 27 m droht
auf die erde zu stürzen
das raumschiff fliegt unkontrolliert
durch das all und droht auf die erde zu
stützen
angefangen hat alles am dienstagmorgen
in kasachstan der frachter nahm den
weiten weg zur raumstation aus sich er
war noch nicht lange unterwegs da musste
die bodenkontrolle melden dass sie den
kontakt verloren hatte die trägerrakete
vom typ sojus 2 1a sich weit vom kurs ab
und brachte progress m 27 m in eine
falsche umlaufbahn
der weltraumfrachter sei stark ins
wanken gekommen und jede bemühung
dagegenzusteuern scheiterte
wenn das team am boden ist nicht schafft
kontakt aufzunehmen können der frachter
etwa im zeitraum vom 7
bis 11 mai nun kontrolliert auf die erde
zurück stürzen an bord des weltraum
frachters progress m 27 m befinden sich
in etwa 2,3 tonnen nachschub für die
bemannte weltraumstation iss 500
kilogramm treibstoff 400 kilogramm
lebensmittel und ersatzteile sollen die
iss erreichen besorgniserregend ist vor
allem das sojus 2 1a nicht nur
unbemannter raumfrachter ins all
verfrachtet sondern schon ende mai
wieder menschen transportieren sollte
dieser termin kann wohl nicht
wahrgenommen werden wenn progress m 27 m
tatsächlich in richtung erde stürzt
würde er zum größten teil verbrennen
jedoch können einige teile dennoch den
boden erreichen eine direkte bedrohung
für die besatzung der iss stelle der
verlust des nachschubs vor es nicht da
sie seien bis zum herbst ausreichend
versorgt bei einem absturz ist mit einem
schaden von bis zu 88 millionen euro zu
rechnen denn soviel kostet zu an staaten
die eine landung einer rakete schief
gehen kann
das steht hier im oben im video
evakuierung auf der uss also da können
das sehen und space extraction eur 740
millionen euro rakete zu rap und zum
blog geht es hier unten und was meint
ihr zu mobbing kein problem gemobbt wird
immer schon unter menschen oder mobbing
geht
eigentlich schreibt es in die kommentare
und ansonsten wie immer bis dann bleibt
dran